hi and welcome to episode number 25 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
i am princess convoy and i'm here with
my colleague knock mandal hi mark how
you doing hey front-desk how are you
doing I'm good so uh we're gonna be
interviewing someone that I really like
actually two people that work very
closely with me yeah about go yeah one
person who actually it's very close to
both of us yeah actually yeah we're
gonna have two people that work in the
developer relations team for go and go
Google cloud platform yep and we're
gonna be talking about why go is cool
for the cloud and how you can use
etcetera etc yeah we'll be talking with
Andrew gerund and Chris Broadfoot yep
both Australians but yeah you're just
gonna be surrounded by Australian can I
scare about that yeah after that though
we're going to have a great question of
the week we're going to talk about some
trade-offs with bigquery versus data
flow yep that's a very interesting
question that apparently some people
tried to like when's you once you start
trying to decide where to go well you
have both both can do similar things
which one is the best one so we'll
discuss that at the end but first we're
gonna talk about the cool thing of the
week absolutely so this was a video that
um came past my desk earlier this week
that I quite liked if anyone's played
the eve online multiplayer game Frances
kind oh you're a big fan yes again I
should play video games more often cuz i
did not know who humble humble bundle
where and i still don't know who if fan
fest look it looks like a cool video
game version of Star Wars yeah so if
you're not familiar with Avon line at a
like literally massively multiplayer
online space exploration and conquest
type game it's the sort of game where
people set up you know like betrayals
from like a year or two years in advance
and people lose thousands and thousands
of dollars a real money based on like
wedding game currency it their stuff
that's happened in that game that is hit
like relative news like it's it's pretty
amazing
kinda like relative you really do like
outside of gaming news where yeah that's
a cool game I don't personally play it
but I know people to do and it's pretty
awesome but we have a video where they
have a presentation they gave about
Cooper nidhi's and how they run at the
company behind Eve what I like about
this presentation i think is quite
interesting apart from the fact that it
gives some background on communities and
how that works but they talk about how
they sort of on-boarded communities into
their organization the impetus behind it
and sort of they they break it down
there like okay so we started building
communities like on-prem and we ran into
some issues and then we started playing
with google cloud platform and that was
a lot easier and like we started going
that way and then they do you know that
we're using container engine directly
they are using container engine they do
mention it basically they don't want to
manage their masters they basically went
we don't want to manage any of the stuff
ourselves which is a great story for us
but I think what's also particularly
interesting is how they on board it
inside their organization and what
services they use it for so this sort of
were like okay let's let's start with
something least critical like let's
build use it for sei systems right build
systems and once they sort of did that
they were like this is amazing like we
want to do it more and so maybe for a
dev tools and our authoring tools like
sort of creeping up at that critical
list of stuff inside the company nice as
they talk about they haven't like fully
permeated all the way through but you
know they're trying to drive that as
much as possible and it's really
interesting to see like how you take
this sort of thing and say okay how can
we sort of step by step bring this into
a company with the least amount of risk
yeah now that that sounds very
interesting i know that there's a lot of
companies out there that are considering
moving to kerbin at ease at least a part
of it so yeah listening to success
stories from others could be could be
very good yeah definitely cool so I
guess it's time to go talk with our
extra two Australian friends absolutely
always always appreciate some
Australians thank you so much to Andrew
and Chris for joining us this late
afternoon here in San Francisco how are
you both doing it's a pleasure to be
here and I'm good answering his question
cool so why don't we start by maybe you
creates telling us a little bit of who
you are what do you do at Google Who am
I so I'm Chris Broadfoot i joined the
cloud and go teams at Google about a
year ago and I'm working on getting the
go to run on cloud and and get that
experience to be as good as possible
what about you yeah I'm a droid your end
and I work on and go I'm am actually
based in Sydney but I'm visiting San
Francisco at the moment you lovely
people and I basically am responsible
for the go user experience I guess from
you know api's to documentation to
educational things and and so on and
dolls tools yes come for your tools and
yeah I have a some thing as in the cloud
pies I guess having done a bunch of
library work and stuff and work with the
go cloud team as well the metaphorical
cloud pie it's delicious I am so cool so
since you both worked in with go and the
go team for quite a while could you tell
us a little bit about for the people
that the know ago is what is going why
is it so important and amazing balsa go
is a programming language that was
developed here at Google and we built it
as a solution to problems that we have
here at Google so it's designed for with
with building sort of distributed
systems in mind and so this is really
important in the cloud space because a
lot of the design decisions we made in
designing go for use inside Google are
also really applicable to people who
build cloud software one of the the most
sort of prominent and obvious of those
is go support for concurrency it
provides some lightweight threading
model based around the notion of go
routines and then it provides some some
other things for synchronizing and
communicating between those routines
lightweight threads and you know using
those concurrency primitives you can
old really nice concurrent software and
pretty much most of the software that
people build in the cloud space is
concurrent in some way and so go is
really nice natural fit for people who
who want to build cloud software and
it's it's nice because it's quite
approachable you know if you've used any
language which has the sea like syntax
you'll understand vaguely what go code
does if you see it for the first time
and so it's very easy people to spin up
on and it's been we've seen a lot of our
cloud customers choose to use go not
knowing anything about go and then have
a really good time doing it and that
seems to be a story that we hear over
and over again is that people teams will
try writing some gross stuff from them
they sort of fall in love with it so
definitely matches my experience I
started using go well before I joined
the go team just as my choice for App
Engine and I'll surprised how quickly i
was super productive and could write you
know moderately correct concurrent
programs using us a little bit more
about your experience writing go on
opinion like what what are the like have
arranged something big that you could
talk about yeah so i worked for many
consecutive years on the Santa tracker
project I don't know how many people
listening a familiar with it but
basically every Christmas a bunch of
engineers from google get together and
write a fun web app that tracks and
Rosie flies around the world and at
least for the last three or four years
the backend has run on App Engine and
writing services was relatively easy
obviously with something at a large
scale you want to do things like load
testing but it was relatively
straightforward to get this app to scale
to a very large number of queries
obviously you want to write your app
with your particular use case in mind
and so in this case we had a lot of very
similar queries so things like caching
using memcache and data store were very
simple to do and yeah we didn't have any
problem any production problem
really and go app engine scale to you
know about 50 instances to serve many
thousands of queries per second so that
and the throughput from go was very good
you know many hundreds of qbs / App
Engine instance and they're not they're
not particularly big instances really
and it's nice that since since you wrote
that in the first place the actual go
runtime has seen a huge overhaul and
it's now actually a lot faster and can
handle a lot more concurrent load than
it than it used to yeah that's true yeah
it's it's been a while since I ran load
tests against it and you know
improvements to go 1.6 probably would
make a significant difference as well
very cool there's another project that I
also like a lot a vibe rumor correctly
there was the a doodle that was powered
by go oh yeah so I guess a few years ago
now there was a google doodle which was
for thanksgiving where you could like
tweak the turkey too there was like a
turkey illustration and you could like
change the feathers of the turkey and
its clothes and stuff like that and a
hat and evidence kit was kind of
ridiculous but people loved it and you
could hit like a random button and it
would be like randomly composed these
various things so when you had a
customized turkey you could share it and
when you shared it it had to be shared
as an image and so there was the most of
this most of the durable took place in
javascript in in the app but then when
you did a share you needed to actually
share like a jpeg of the turkey so the
the the Go app would compose the turkey
image based on the various layers over
layers and so just did some image
processing and then spat out a generated
jpg and when you launch anything on the
front page of google com it kind of
takes a huge huge amount of load and go
on App Engine scaled gracefully to to to
meet the demand and it was so we
actually have a member of the doodle
team who'd never used go before wrote
the app from scratch I won't say it was
perfect I think I you know who had a few
review comments but it was um
it performed well and it performed
reliably and did the job and you know
and I think it's still running things on
App Engine generally you can deploy it
and still have it running I visited a
nap I deployed maybe three or four years
ago and it was still working yeah I mean
I don't know if they still enable the
share and stuff I don't know how they
archive the doodles in retrospect but it
was certainly nice for me because I had
been working on the original launch of
go on App Engine and you know this was
kind of like the first person that came
along and said uh you know I want to use
it for something and and and and it
worked as we expected it to you know you
you sort of spent all this time building
things in you it's not until you
actually see it in the hands of a user
that you really know that it's a you
made the right choices so I decided to
show it actually still works even the
share buttons the works we should link
to it in yeah we'll link to it on the on
the show notes verena maybe people will
be tweaked and go for Bauer turkeys
podcast yeah yeah we talked a little
about scale obviously in terms of load
and whatnot but I think one of the
interesting things about go particularly
is kind of like go format which i think
is the correct way to set and I people
say go go fund your font it's about geo
FMT now I can't deal with that but um I
think it's really interesting like from
the outset that was like this is the way
to write code this is the syntax format
that it needs to come in and that lets
you scale in terms of teams wanna talk a
little bit about that one of my one of
my things that I do in talks sometimes
is they say raise your hand if you've
ever had an argument with a colleague
about formatting like code formatting
and it's always the entire room with the
hands up and them is like and keep your
hand up if you thought that was a
productive use of your time yeah and you
know all the hands go down and I think
everyone's had this experience where one
person likes it one way and the other
person likes it another way and there's
really no like everyone has an argument
but there's no really objective truth as
to what the best styles are on so go
from just makes those decisions for you
and you just have
the canonical go style that everyone
uses and it's not anyone's favorite
style it's not like the go team have
this opinion about brace position or
tabs versus spaces or whatever we just
made some decisions and that's it and
it's a yeah I mean it's a really nice
thing and we get a lot of good feedback
from people who you know have
engineering teams or generally the
longer somebody's been in the software
industry the more they appreciate having
go fund I think it kind of what
motivated us ubers that at Google in
other languages we have these very
meticulous style guides and so a lot of
code reviews end up becoming this sort
of really fixated on the minutiae of the
code rather than looking at the
correctness or the the API design or you
know the things that are really
important when running software it's
just fewer things to think about yeah
and there's actually a really nice sort
of version of go fund called go imports
which is functionally the same and
reformats code but it also will look at
the a of the names that you've used
inside the source code and update your
import statements like they include or
you know the equivalent of including
tell you this may be a really stupid
question does go imports do what go
format does as well yes yes yeah oh I
always use one enough together yeah you
do yeah me too you'll never see a import
not used error ever again yep yep or not
found yeah no I like that that's sort of
philosophy and I think that also goes to
like I think when people start using go
sometimes they sort of see it is a
fairly verbose language but I think to a
degree or so that's caught of its power
and that you can look at it and see what
is happening as each each step you know
through the programming language there's
no there's no real magic there and what
you see is what you get and you can dig
into the core libraries and be like okay
what is this thing doing and it's you're
not like oh there's like some special
flag that this magic compiler has that
only the special libraries get to use
it's all pretty standard stuff yeah I
think that's also a dick ative of a
greater trend in the software industry
to
like the last time I use Java was maybe
three or four years ago and I think Java
development has changed significantly
since then although the language has
also changed I don't think that the way
people approach programming is simply
because of language changes its people
it's because people don't want to spend
time figuring out why their application
behavior changes because of
configuration or you know some random
file that's it's unrelated and I think
the simplicity of go kind of reflects a
change in the way people are approaching
things in general yeah I mean I didn't
even think like Java cops a lot of crap
for being you know factories of
factories of factories and all that kind
of stuff but someone typed the word
factory right so yeah read those it's
not yeah and you know there it is
possible to write nice java programs
it's just the way it is used the culture
that that grew around it in this sort of
enterprise space or whatever is
unfortunately overly complicated yeah
and we don't mean to disparage just Java
i guess i mean it's true javascript it's
true in even in python there are lots
and lots of different ways to do things
in python and you know just generally in
in software as a whole i think you know
it sort of started off nice and then it
just keeps getting more and more complex
so go and goes existence is kind of a
reaction to this sort of tide of
complexity but i do think goes the only
project in the programming landscape
that's focused on simplicity I mean
predating goers say rich Hickey with a
closure and he has a strong emphasis on
simplicity was a great talk that he gave
simplicity made easy which talks about
all of these things the core of it is
that you actually have to try really
hard to keep things simple and I think
complexity is just something that
naturally arises in nature as well as in
human endeavors so you know we kind of
you go put the brakes on a bit sometimes
to to try how to keep things small and
comprehensible and so on often you just
have to kind of redo and
just start again sometimes not
necessarily talking about programming
languages but sometimes your code like
sometimes it's just better to redo
something so since since we've come
we've covered a little bit about the
origins of go and elevated the
philosophy behind it we could talk not a
little bit about why do you think that
go is so successful in the cloud
nowadays like there's darker there's
goober Nettie's there's so many like
basically any company that has cloud
somewhere in the name they're using go
why do you think this is I think it goes
back to what we talked about at the very
beginning of the podcast about
concurrency and I don't think we
mentioned networking but I think go as a
fantastic language for dealing with
networking partly because it's great for
concurrency but particularly writing web
applications I've found that it's you
know just the standard net HTTP package
and all of the libraries around it
create a really nice working environment
for creating web applications and I
think I think everyone in the community
recognizes that too yeah I think it
generally just gives you the tools that
you need to write those kind of things
and also you know I guess one of the
reasons it makes sense the docker for
instance is written in go is that it
spends a lot of time talking to the
operating system and go makes it really
easy to understand the the interface
between go and the operating system you
know it's it you can just walk through
the standard library and see where the
SIS calls are being made and how that
happens and you know if you need to do
more it's pretty straightforward to to
understand how to make the rosses calls
or talk to lipsy or you know any of
those things so it kind of just it puts
you a lot closer to the system and then
you would feel in well I guess any
language that has like a runtime like
your mouth on a Java room you know but
if you're using see your kind of using
lipsy and then lipsy is a whole nother
thing in itself but also you know go as
a memory safe language so you know you
could be using C and then you have to
worry about all the security issues that
come with that and you know we continue
to see so many exploits yeah the memory
safety of co is actually a really
important feature and one that doesn't
get spoken
much simply because most almost all
modern languages a memory safe now yeah
as a previous C++ programmer I know that
one of my favorite things of go is the
fact that this there's no memory
corruption yeah that is HUGE segfaults
yeah like that that dead little thing
that people forget about that's a that's
amazing so yeah do you also feel I mean
go is not the only language that will
combine down to a single library but it
seemed to be the reaction against a lot
of languages that have run times that
are bundled that ease of deployment and
that's where staff do you feel like
that's also been a big factor yeah a lot
of people talk about it you know just
build you can you can you know on my Mac
I can build a linux amd64 binary and SCP
it to a vm somewhere and you know it
just works and you don't need to worry
about any of the dependencies or
bundling or anything like that um I
think definitely compared to any of the
what am I trying to say runtime JVM
runtime ya like like no node or Python
or even Java I mean you still have to
have some story about bundling up your
depths yeah even also the runtime
version you know you end up with things
like IBM and tools like that to figure
out what version you're running under
which is often very important there's
just a lot more code to link against I
guess and having them at runtime this
also just makes things a list a less
predictable mmm and I guess in in the
cloud sins in the docker container you
can create a docker container that just
has the go binary in it and nothing else
and that's it yeah and that's kind of
nice it's a very easy thing to
understand in this world that's
complicated and difficult to understand
cool so for people that are where they
convinced on using go and using go on
the cloud what are the different ways
that they can run gogogo platformer yeah
so there are many ways that vary from
very managed to not being managed at all
so some of my favorites a Google App
Engine I I don't like messing with
deployment scripts and things like that
I mostly right web applications so there
are really great fit we have to sort of
flavors I guess and so there's app
engine standard environment and this is
what we used to call a sandbox
environment has quite a few restrictions
around how you program your application
so you're not likely to run an existing
go application directly on App Engine
standard but you can basically do that
with App Engine flexible environment
which has far fewer restrictions like
you have a main function and a main
package so you basically run the same
application outside of App Engine as you
do on your desktop or on a different
cloud provider we also have COO
benetti's which is a essentially an open
source version of the deployment system
we use at Google which is called Borg mm
and and this lets you run your
application on many different nodes on
any computer very easily there's also
compute engine which is basically just a
bare vm and you know this this means you
have to run your own deployment scripts
and startup scripts and manage all of
that yourself however we do provide
things like Colonel patches and things
like that on the fly so it's you know
still very different to having a
computer sitting under your stairs right
yeah I was so in the compute engine case
you basically just get nothing yeah in
terms of scaling and and so on but then
in the in the App Engine cases either
App Engine standard or flex you can take
care you can take advantage of the the
auto scaling infrastructure that we have
so if your app gets a lot of incoming
requests suddenly load spike it can
quickly spin up various instances of
your more instance of your app and serve
more requests volume the key advantage
that that standard has over flex is that
it can spin up instances very very
quickly the the entire infrastructure is
is built around kind of keeping keeping
like hot spares of like blank slate
instances that can then just basically
copy your app and launch it
whereas with with Flex you need to each
new instance has to spin up a new vm to
serve that instance so if you can work
within the the standard App Engine
environment it's actually a really nice
way to build software it doesn't let you
do things like write to the file system
and you need to use our AP is to make
like external Network requests and so on
but it we've we've done our best to kind
of make it feel really natural to do
that from inside go and if you you if
generally if you use the the App Engine
standard packages you will write an app
that will scale that's that's kind of
the the whole premise of App Engine is
that you know we give you the API is to
use that if you use them you know you
won't write an unscalable app I mean
it's definitely still possible yeah but
the the way it's designed kind of makes
it natural to do it it's also great for
small apps you know as I said before I
have a multitude of toy apps that
continue running without any oversight
at all and I think that's another a real
strength of the App Engine platform it's
a very lightweight mm Oh an app engine
standard will run 0 instances of your
app if it's no one's using it yeah so
you don't even pay for your app when
people aren't using it which is a
definite advantage over the vm based
yeah we had a couple episodes ago we
interviewed a humble bundle and they run
the whole infrastructure basically on
App Engine and they were talking about
all of these benefits like if they get a
huge spike in traffic they don't care
everything just works yeah so I should
mention another another thing we're
working on is a set of packages and
libraries that sort of bridge these gaps
so that you know if you start with App
Engine standard and need to do something
a little more special you can move to
the manage the flexible environment
previously known as managed VMs and you
know sort of move between these
different deployment modes and not have
to rewrite your application because you
know applications should be agnostic of
where they're deployed you know you
should just write your application and
be able to deploy it wherever you like
and however you like so that's that's
another focus and and real goal of the
Google cloud platform right
mmm yeah I gotta say that one of my
favorite things for out of all the
packages is the way oughtn't occation
works with basically go on any of the
clouds it is it is super simple it's
basically two lines of code saying just
get the default credentials and
everything just works yeah that is super
nice yeah definitely so if people have
been listening the episode and they're
particularly interested in letting go or
possibly go on Google cloud platform
what are your favorite ways of learning
those things well I think first of all
you should learn go yeah the best way to
do that is the the goat or which and
rewrote yeah it's tour going dog and
yeah you can just go through use a web
browser and learn the features of
language I've done that and yeah I think
it's a pretty good way to get started I
definitely recommend like having a
project in mind like something simple
that you can just like try in and make
being a lot of people try and absorbed a
lot of information in the abstract
before trying to apply in that's just my
personal styles to actually have
something in mind and now if you want
and then if you want to move into the
cloud space we have a cloud or
google.com / go which has a great
introductory app a bookshelf app for
organizing books something we all get I
think we all do yes I meticulously
catalogued my book collection in this
app not really but it's a it's a great
demo of how all the pieces fit together
in the deployment story and all that
stuff there's also a couple other
resources if you go into the cloud
console and I think if you press app
engine there are some guided flows so
you don't even need to download the SDK
to your local machine or anything like
that use the cloud shell which is
basically a virtual machine that runs
the cloud tools and so you do everything
through a web interface and that's
that's a pretty great way to just get a
feel for the for Google cloud platform
and App Engine and then there's also
another repository where we're adding a
lot of samples to and sort of
consolidating
samples and so that's github com /
google cloud platform / golang samples
will put a link in yeah and yeah so you
can just take a look in there and see a
bunch of different samples and how
things fit together cool so we're pretty
much out of time but is there anything
else that you like to add check out the
turkeys I think that rabbits are the
superior domestic pet just thought I'd
throw that out there better than Gophers
I don't know anyone who keeps the
gophone if you keep it go for please
write to me adg at girl underdog okay
you have your experiences great well
thank you very much thank you thanks
guys thank you thanks so much to Andrew
and Chris for joining us today that was
a really interesting conversation and
was an absolute pleasure to talk to you
both but we have a really interesting
question of the week Francesca would you
like to head that off yeah so it's a
question that comes to us through the I
forgot the name slack channel through
the slack channel exactly we have a
podcast like channel in the Google cloud
platform community and the question is
okay so when do you transform your data
in bigquery via queries versus data flow
for etl it's an interesting question
right because in theory you could do it
either way yeah so I think that the
thing to keep in mind here is that
bigquery is a very specific tool with
very specific use case which is
basically log analysis it will do more
than that it will do basically analysis
of any kind of structured data where the
analysis that you're trying to do
matches pretty much what you consider a
sequel query and for those that don't
know about what etl is basically etl is
a way of processing data and it's about
extract transform and load so it's like
you extract the data you transform it in
some way and then you store it into your
data warehouse and bigquery is more
about once that data has been loaded
into the into the data warehouse you can
extract information out of all that data
so if you're doing something like you
have a lot of data and you want to do an
average over all the values or you want
to find some specific grows and stuff
like that that is basically what big
what big purpose will build for but
bigquery doesn't do everything there's
things like for instance if you're
trying to do things with images or
really anything that is not structured
just not just text it's not really going
to work with bigquery so in that case
you're good you should use data flow and
data flow it's it's basically if you've
never heard about data flow but you've
heard about MapReduce data flow is like
a generalization of what MapReduce does
so instead of having just the sub
MapReduce it's an interview a question
how many faces that's my producers have
how many faces yeah like eyes nose and
ears now phases Oh phases making fun of
my accent no no I didn't understand your
apartment so how many phases are they in
MapReduce that's a great question
francisc how many phases are there in my
produce one could say map and reduce ya
know there's map shuffle and reduce but
you don't say map shuffle reduced
because it could be too long but so
basically it's you get those three
phases and you make them composable so
it's like a generalization you have as
many phases as you want so that allows
you to do whatever you want so it's
really powerful in so if you want to do
something that matches the bigquery use
case go with bigquery otherwise data
flow will be there for you and data flow
is also very good for specific use case
which is real time analysis and
streaming yep that make sense so if you
want to like window your data or like
know exactly how many times something's
happened last half hour or something
like that exactly there's also I've seen
some of them was basically demonstrating
how to implement the Twitter a trainer
trending yeah trend the hashtag ran
trending that you can implement that we
did a flow quite easily really okay cool
excellent I so it sounds like if I have
structured data it fits in bigquery and
it you know hits that paradigm I should
just use bigquery but absolute of it but
if I sit sort of outside of that
paradigm then I might as well use data
flow because it gives me more
flexibility and what
need to do yeah if you can just be query
you speak ray you will not regret it and
if you can use it then use data flow and
you can write whatever you need
excellent well that sounds like awesome
stuff um but I think we're going to be
traveling around a little bit France
esque in the next couple of weeks you
can be anywhere special is there
anything happening in the next few weeks
we should mention i'm going to this
incredible place the happiest place in
the earth easy lad na months of you oh
yeah yeah we're gonna be month of you
for Google i/o and that's gonna be
pretty awesome I'm working on my lats
not so necessary my dads are pretty much
ready we're gonna I'm gonna be talking
about about cloud spin yeah and you were
talking about I'm doing a session of
multiplayer games with firebase cool so
that's a lot of fun that sounds very
interesting you you're doing a lot of
video games lately I like video games
they're fun that is cool and after that
i would go to go to chi cago nice yep
first time there i will be talking about
go tooling very excited about that one
I'm excited because i'll be getting
while be staying up till 1am to do a
presentation for GDG Melbourne that's
going to be lots of fun and after that I
probably will be heading off to yes I'll
be a is doing several stints off to
Minneapolis actually in June which would
be lots of fun but one event that I
definitely want to bring up that's going
to be on jun 3rd is change the game
development summit here in San Francisco
or in june third at the google
headquarters here in San Francisco cool
so if you're interested in game
development on the cloud multiplayer
games analytics big data with games all
that sort of good stuff definitely come
check us out it's a free event you can
come down we definitely still have seats
available i'll be presenting there with
some ppl pocket gems will be there cab
and we'll be there some other from
people like that so we'd love to see you
cool maybe i should mention that right
after that i will be gone for a week
well yeah so i will be biking from San
Francisco to Los Angeles yeah so I'm
going to be doing the aids lifecycle and
I'm looking for donations I've already
donated yeah thank you so much
so yeah I don't know with that month
that that week maybe we'll do a podcast
on the road or something yeah Oh a
pre-recorded well sir I it will find
something out yeah wonderful well
francisc thank you so much for joining
me yet again for another episode thank
you so much mark for being here and
helping me understand to other
Australians sometimes the accent gets
hard no problem and definitely speak to
you next week yeah talk to you next week
you